from a scientists perspective it's gonna
be rather different from that of most
religious traditions which hold that we
die because this is only a temporary
staging area before we go to the Big
Show the next stage in which we go to
heaven or hell or wherever some kind of
afterlife for scientists the question
has a rather different answer and it has
to do with the kinds of causes we look
for in science so you have proximate
causes versus ultimate causes for
example why does sugar taste sweet or
why does fruit taste sweet something
like that you'd say well because there's
molecular receptors on your tongue that
are geared toward sending signals to a
certain part of the brain that register
sweetness and pleasure and so on with
fruit that's a proximate answer an
ultimate answer is because foods that
taste sweet are more likely to be
consumed and those in our natural
environment are the kinds of foods that
are both rare and nutritious and so the
more of them you eat the better and and
and we evolve that tendency so to answer
the question why we die it's the same
kind of thing approximate answers
include cancer heart disease artha
sclerosis the ultimate answer though is
found in two principles of nature that
is the second law of thermodynamics or
entropy which means everything runs down
including our bodies and in the whole
universe the whole universe runs down so
ultimately even if you could double your
life span triple it live you know
essentially forever you can't really
because the universe will eventually die
in a heat death so and then second is
the principle of natural selection that
drives evolution and it has to do with
the cost-benefit analysis of how many
limited resources you put into organisms
so obviously natural selection is going
to select for infants and toddlers and
babies to be well cared for have super
regenerative powers to keep their bodies
going in order to get the genes into the
next generation get them up to
reproductive age and so on so we see
cells that divide very rapidly in
infants and babies you know a little cut
you can practically watch it heal it's
incredible whereas someone
when I get cut it takes much longer to
heal and and so the question is why why
wouldn't evolution just make it so that
I now in my early sixties can't just
keep going to 200 300 and the answer is
there's no no reason for it because
after I've brought my own offspring into
reproductive age and then they've
brought their offspring into
reproductive age I'm really of no use
anymore I can serve a useful purpose as
a parent of course bringing my genes up
and then the useful purpose is a
grandparent to help my offspring bring
their offspring up to reproductive age
but beyond that really there's no sense
and pouring any more resources into
great-great-great great-great
grandparents because the genes and the
little infant are already going to be
well taken care of so it's sort of a
weird way to think about it but in a way
the nature operates because of entropy
nature asked to select and choose and
kind of a triage where are we going to
put the resources now I'm saying it like
there's somebody up there
you know allocating resources there's
you know the the government's doling out
checks to organisms no there's nothing
like that of course this is just how
natural selection operates so in short
we die so that our future generations
may live because there are limited
resources
[Music]